zach wheeler finished the
first half of the season with a 2.26 era
in 18
games at ball four
chisholm walks this way you're gonna
miss
oh
[Applause]
wheeler picks up his second strike out
of the inning no runs
seventh overall pick by the marlins in
2016 out of high school in
alabama one of their top prospects last
couple of seasons braxton garrett
his third start of 2021 fifth in his
career
this one is floated out towards shallow
right and it's out of the reach of
jazz chisholm junior who comes down hard
in right field and it looked like he's
holding his left shoulder
[Applause]
head athletic trainer gene basham out to
check on jazz
don mattingly out there as well
and jazz seems to be in
a great deal of pain right now and that
is
not a good sign for the marlins here it
comes from
garrett and hoskins with a fly ball out
to left center field
sierra into the game after the injury
makes the play
oh two pitch coming he went around
he was tied up big time three strikeouts
in a row
and there's one out so now second and
third for segura
and it gets away from alfaro here comes
terres he'll score
the phillies are on the board it's one
nothing
that'll bring jt up with two outs and
runners on first and third and he lines
that one
sharply off the chest of rojas slips to
second not
in time run scores
two nothing fills hustle by secure
segura was fantastic
how about braxton garrett with a base
hit or
yes yes braxton geared with a base hit
we can't confirm
they will call for the baseball for
braxton garrett his first big league hit
marta fly ball right center field hit
well that's going to one-hop the wall
braxton garrett's going to score they
will hold sierra it's an rbi
double for starling marte
and cooper out to right field harper
makes the catch
sierra with terrific speed on his way
home
and the throw just a little late a
sacrifice fly
for garrett cooper home runs on pitches
that are low and away but adam duvall
with 18 of them
since the start of last year that's low
and away
that's lifted to right that is a home
run
adam duvall two
run shot for duvall is 20th of the
season and the marlins get
four on the board in the third
[Applause]
that's well hit going back on it is
duvall and it's off the scoreboard it
kicks to his
left and reese to second base
with his 24th double of the year hoskins
who doubled stands away from third
2-2 on the way to reyes in the year left
field
sierra moves over to make the play
line drive caught by wheeler right on
the mound as cool
as a cucumber all right so here's
mccutchen
that's a hanger that's drilled deep to
left field forget about that one
andrew mccutchen just pulled the fills
to within
one of his 16th home run of the
lefties have great swings they have
sweet swings
but man when a righty gets it like that
and that is a
sweet swing
[Applause]
deedy lifts one to deep right field
duvall going back to the scoreboard it's
gone
and this ball game is tied up at four
wow eight home runs
all right listen defensive plays come
from every which way
ben this was awesome
kid me look at this smile on that face
swinging to miss wheeler picks up his
seventh strikeout
[Applause]
over to short charging his deed he
scoops and throws on the run in time
a little bit of a different set of body
language going on for the fills we'll go
to the bottom of the six tied up at four
so now he's got segura with the infield
drawn in halfway up the middle
out towards center field marte settles
under it jankowski
tagging it third he'll score uncontested
phillies take the lead five to four
bases are now loaded and it brings
mccutchen up
grounded shortstop rojas bobbles to
second for one over to first not
in time the bobble costume and a run
scores philly's lead at six to four
coach goes alfaro throws nobody's
covering second coming home is jt
and he is out at home plate
nissan left center field gives it a ride
long run
for mccutcheon not going to get there
jankowski plays it off the wall
and it's a pinch hit double to start the
seventh for east san diego
back to the box and they've got diaz
caught between second and third sierra
is on his way to
second so he'll exchange
ground ball to short stop waiting for it
is dede grigorius
throw across the diamond side is retired
no runs one hit
and one man left
aguilar left field that is going to get
down for a base hit
and now the marlins have the tying runs
on
second a high fly ball to left
it's deep but it's playable god she
makes the catch
swing you're gonna miss they went with
the sinker that was up
and he works out of a bases loaded jam
here in the eighth inning
that's nick maton in the on deck circle
with the pitcher spot do up now the bunt
gets dropped down and that's a fair ball
it's alfaro that pounces
and cooper gets tangled up with
jankowski
you always worry about that the wrist
and
the elbow and that's exactly what cooper
is holding right now
in a great deal of pain
an rbi single for jt
7-4 phillies a little insurance
and now hector nearest on to try to
record a save
and again the 2-2 pitch
he got him hector neris his first
save in three weeks
since the 25th of june the fills
win both today and take three of four
from the marlins